oui bonjour et merci merci d'être d'être
de nous accompagner dans cette édition
spéciale alors c'est vrai qu'on rappelle
dans un premier temps
l'état des lieux des forces en présences
où se situent les forces russes au
moment où l'on se parle même s'il est
évidemment extrêmement complexe est de
savoir exactement qui se trouve où en
attendant il y à cette avancée et 7
cette invasion qui s'est fait et au sol
et dans les airs la nuit dernière selon
vous la nuit qui arrivent les russes
ont-ils intérêt à durcir encore à
nouveau cette opération ou à calmer le
jeu au vu des nombreuses prises de
paroles nombreuses décisions qui
pourraient intervenir je pense
évidemment aux américains qui avaient
été dix et ont plutôt alarmistes ces
derniers jours on va entendre les mots
de joe biden dans quelques instants il
va sûrement se féliciter d'avoir vu
juste dans ce qui est en train de se
passer en ukraine ya aussi les européens
qui se retrouvent à 20h ce soir à à
bruxelles selon vous les russes que
risque-t-il de faire dans les heures qui
viennent
j'ai pas le sentiment que jusqu'à
présent toute l'action dissuasive des
occidentaux et beaucoup fait changer les
calculs de l'avenir guînes donc sans une
très grande détermination donc les
menaces de sanctions je pense qu'elle
soit était déjà déroulé justement de
manière dissuasive dans les précédents
jours ça n'a visiblement rien dissuadé
bon départ que ça ça ne soit pas
suffisant et que dans la mesure où les
pays occidentaux et les etats unis ont
dit qu'il n'y aurait pas d'intervention
militaire pour l'ukraine au profit de
l'ukraine j'ai peur que la détermination
de la victime qui sont très très fortes
ne soit pas en talent lui y compris sur
son propre sol vous évoquez la
détermination du chef du kremlin les
autorités russes ont premier aujourd'hui
de réprimer est toute manifestation non
autorisée organisé dans le pays contre
cette guerre en ukraine évidemment tout
le monde allait regarder les yeux
braqués envers cette population russe
voir s'ils vont nous soutenir leur
président ça va être difficile autrement
pour eux alors déjà à gaza il ya cette
restriction qui pèsent sur eux il ya
quelques une centaine de journalistes et
d'experts qui ont fait lettre ouverte au
président pour interrompre cette guerre
ce qui peut être considéré comme
courageux dans les circonstances
actuelles un certain nombre d'artistes
aussi qui se sont exprimés contre contre
cette guerre après d'une façon générale
la population russe c'est vrai qu'elle
est à la fois
élevé depuis plusieurs années même
plusieurs décennies dans l'idée que
l'occident est un adversaire qu'il veut
soustraire l'ukraine pays amis pays
frère à
ses liens à la russie etc donc voilà les
sondages que les russes ont tendance à
considérer que ce qui se produit en fait
était de la faute des occidentaux et en
même temps on sent une fatigue aussi
dans les mêmes sondages de la population
russe par rapport à tout ce qui est
aventure militaire aventure
internationale et puis je dirais que
quand même il ya effectivement des liens
très spéciaux entre l'ukraine et la
russie aient les populations en tout cas
et si je ne pense pas que la souris sont
considère parce que c'est aussi le
message dominant dans la presse et dans
les médias télévisuels que le
gouvernement ukrainien est responsable
de tous aux mains des occidentaux est un
adversaire je pense que quand même entre
la vision des populations plus sur la
population ukrainienne est probablement
moins négative et ça me paraît pas
évident que les russes soient d'un
soutien à poutine sur cette bière mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'il y aura de
nombreuses manifestations et comme vous
l'avez dit de toute façon même les plus
petites manifestations sont il y aurait
déjà quelques dizaines de personnes
soixantaine de d'arrestation de réaliser
selon les ong spécialisées au v des
infos donc en russie des russes qui
auraient voulu témoigner de leur
opposition à cette à cette guerre et
deux sont déjà derrière les barreaux
alexeï navalni lui aussi s'est exprimé
et a condamné un cette guerre aussi
étonnant que ce soit ce matin depuis
depuis sa présence continue de
communiquer donc on est dans un vrai
contexte de propagande d'un côté comme
de l'autre on lisait tout à l'heure le
président ukrainien a choisi l'année
dernière de s'adresser aux russes en
russe à quel point c'est important de
leur parler aux russes aujourd'hui de
s'adresser g c'est justement sans doute
un peu en référence c'est ce que je me
disais tout à l'heure avec l'idée que
probablement la population russe 1 n'a
pas envie d'une nouvelle aventure
militaire à un moment où elle est quand
même plus concentré sur ses problèmes
économiques matériel sur la gestion de
la pandémie au vide et aussi parce que
justement il ya déjà eu quelques
aventures de ce titre ces dernières
années et il sait aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de liens interpersonnels entre
les populations des deux pays et c'est
sans doute sur cela qu'ils disent et
c'est aussi pour distinguer la
population russe de ses dirigeants
le président russe qui a déclaré
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas idée à quel
point la réponse pourrait être forte en
direction de tous ceux qui qui
s'opposeraient à cette opération
aujourd'hui la russie qui est premier au
moment où je vous parle une réplique
sévère aux sanctions de l'union
européenne on va répondre coup pour coup
on a ces images
en direct que je découvre en même temps
vous ont peut-être les voir à l'image en
plein pot ces images de nuit de moscou
et de ses quelques manifestants qui
tentent de s'exprimer c'est ces camions
de police qui eux aussi sont présents
ont évoqué cette cette opposition des
russes qu'est ce qui pourrait les faire
lâcher vladimir poutine finalement
demain alors qu'on ne cesse de dire
depuis des semaines que les sanctions
contre les rues ça ne fonctionne pas ça
n'a pas d'effet si les russes voient
leur leur frigo se vider leur pouvoir
d'achat a reculé ça ça pourrait
davantage leur parler
alors ça me prouve l avantage leur
parler mais je pense pas que ce sera un
effet vraiment immédiat d'abord parce
que la russie est soumise la sanction
déjà depuis de nombreuses années mais là
c'est vrai qu'on passera dans une autre
dans une autre dimension
ensuite là aussi pour l'instant un
matelas de sécurité puisqu'elle a des
réserves à hauteur d'environ 600 650
milliards de dollars il ya aussi les
prix du pétrole qui est déjà assez élevé
et qui vont probablement repartir encore
plus à la hausse dans cette situation
donc pour l'instant sans doute le
pouvoir lui se sont ils plus ou moins à
l'abri en tout cas des chocs d'un choc
immédiat mais sur le long terme c'est
vrai que c'est pas forcément là il y
aura des impacts sur le système bancaire
pense qu'on peut être s'attendre à des
sanctions sur les bancs de plus grande
importance 1 par rapport aux sanctions
qui ont été prises dernièrement et puis
des sanctions sur les transferts de
technologies des technologies sensibles
dont a besoin la russie notamment les
temps qu'on parle beaucoup des semi
conducteurs
mais c'est vrai que la population russe
ne va pas forcément sentir l'impact
immédiatement un mot peut-être des
conséquences pour l'autre l'autre partie
du monde l'autre côté de la planète on
parle des conséquences économiques sur
les russes les conséquences pour les
européens pour les américains
le baril de pétrole à 100 dollars un
danger pour l'économie mondiale aussi
oui je pense que d'ailleurs c'est sans
doute pas l'objectif premier mais je
pense que pour vladimir poutine c'est
sans doute un dommage collatéral qui
pour lequel il va se frotter les mains
c'est de savoir que finalement dans les
sociétés occidentales qui sont également
visés imparable en tout sept cette
situation les occidentaux sont également
visés est un pur d'état des tas de
raisons sur lesquelles je n'ai pas le
temps de revenir et donc l'idée qu'il
puisse y avoir dans les pays européens
des tensions politiques et sociales qui
seraient liées justement à cette flambée
on sait déjà que ça crée des camps sont
dans beaucoup de pays
bien sûr ce n'est pas une perspective
qui lui déplaît énormément
voilà la hausse continue du pétrole qui
est une réalité ici aussi a pris plus de
30% depuis le 1er janvier elle devrait
logiquement continue d'affoler les
compteurs ça on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler un peu plus tard merci beaucoup
en d'avoir été avec nous isabelle facon
merci pour cet